we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P now yesterday during the
show my microphone fell it fell on me
and it actually smacked me in the face
and if you were listening to yesterday's
show you might have heard me say oh I
just lost my microphone and heard a Gunk
for lack of a better term the video of
the microphone falling on me is on my
Instagram which you can find at
david.pakman this listener this viewer
rather
um called in about how close of a call I
had with the microphone yesterday listen
to this
hi David you need to go back and
re-watch your show when your microphone
fell because if you had not looked over
to I guess it would have been your left
that I think that thing would have got
you right in the eye oh my gosh I I
think you're very lucky that you had
it hit the side of your face and not
your eye oh my gosh I'm glad it did not
get you in the eye okay well I am in one
of your Avid fans and a member so I
appreciate your show I enjoy listening
to it every day and
um have a nice day well thank you for
that yeah no I did go back and I watched
it slowly sort of like the Zapruder film
frame by frame and I did take a little
bit of a hit uh on the right side of my
face from the microphone falling had I
been looking in a different direction as
the mic fell it could have gotten me in
the eye and I am not a medical doctor to
be very clear but I think that that
would have been bad I think it might
have uh I don't know that I would be
here hosting necessarily today had that
taken place so if you're curious what
that looked like there is video of it on
my Instagram which you can find at
david.pakman we have a great bonus show
for you today we're down to the final
primaries of 2022. we'll tell you what
they are and what to watch and how
things are looking number two
Alabama is jailing pregnant cannabis
users to protect quote protect the
fetuses what yes and major credit card
companies are making it easier to track
gun sales and the gun people are Furious
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money but everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad well we do fund ourselves yes there
is money exchanged with the bonus show
you can sign up at joinpakman.com you
will get instant access to the bonus
show and I look forward to seeing you
then